your life has been so i mean it probably
gets exhausting with the amount of men
and the amount of attention you've
gotten like do you think you're the most
successful sort of
person to come out of playboy yeah
playboy playmaker yeah you did 14 covers
of playboy your name is known everywhere
around the world most people who go in
playboy have dreams that they're going
to be pamela anderson and they don't
achieve them in fact it's a it's a
letdown kind of they go back to their
hometowns kind of like what the [ __ ]
went wrong
um did you ever say to yourself oh my
god how did this really happen all the
time i don't know how it really happened
i don't know how i'm still doing what
i'm doing and i've raised two pretty
normal kids and tommy and i are really
united as parents and especially lately
as the kids are getting older i'm like
my kids are both over six feet tall and
they're you know they're telling me what
they want i'm telling them what they
want i'm like tommy help you know yeah
this is your time buddy
the boys are good looking boys i mean
you and tommy are very good-looking
people you had good-looking children
their mom is pam anderson their dad is
tommy lee was tommy a good influence
could he step in and uh and and really
take over was he always on tour with mom
he was always on tour he really wasn't
around that much up until now but now we
make a real effort to be even if we
can't all see each other at the same
time we on conference calls and we try
and we'll make sure that we're united
when we talk to our kids and you know
tommy's tough tommy's tommy's really
really um strict wants him to become not
spoiled brat men you know he wants them
to work and work hard and it's we really
are impressing that you're on the same
page with tommy we are on the same page
but our kids right now are a little bit
rebelling can you call tommy i call
tommy yeah and he says tommy emails me
all day breathe be strong this is okay
this is what he needs this is what you
know believe me it's really
we're doing a great job i think because
i look around and i look at other
parents i've never had nannies you know
i did this all myself and i admire tommy
for trying you know he could also say
hey you know what i'll be the good guy
here and undermine you he's not
undermining no we are completely united
and he's not being the the friend he's
being the dad
this this tommy who's the dad and being
good does that make you kind of fall
back in love with him i've never been
out of love with tommy what happened why
it seems to me like maybe that should
have been the perfect union i probably
should have we probably should have
stuck it out i don't know i hope he you
know but again at the time you know it
was thus craziness going on we had all
those people following us around we were
married young married quick we had
babies right away and
and then you know and then i think it
was like the whole point the whole
when he went to jail and everything like
that was he was taking steroids i
thought he was on heroin i was finding
these needles you know it was like he
was trying to get big and for me
for me so it's kind of sad but you know
we still didn't handle ourselves right
and and it fell apart and we tried back
and forth back and forth and i don't
think it's a good do you live in
relationships when you're around him and
and the kids bring back all the good
times you know like hey you know we were
really in love we actually had children
together and the kids know that they
were born out of true love like real
love so they know that so you're still
in love with him
i mean i love him and especially now i
think he's doing such a great job as
he's stepping up as a dad because i
could be on my own right now and what
would i do